who who's your goat who do you think is
the grace of all time bill russell bill
russell for sure over kobe over lebron
over
bill's got 11 championships and and bill
gaine would have translated to today
because he was the most athletic big
deal if you got it if you get if you put
bill russell in today's game
he dominated he he he could block shots
he's gonna rebound everything
he fasted in the guards
how about this lebron or jordan
[Music]
um
that's a tough one well
um
well i'm guarded both
but this is the thing
jordan never lost in the finals lebron
has
lebron's been to 10 of them though right
so but lebron's been attended
um
jordan skipped out on two
now one would argue that houston would
have won all right cool
when jordan won his last one he left
so that was a
we talking nine rings
we talking nine when he came back
averaging 25 he was clearly able to
still play we talking the same type yeah
like if he would have stayed they would
have beat this they would have beat the
spurs because that was the uh i think
that was the lockout yeah yeah that was
the the lockout you know what i'm saying
so it's just like for me it's just like
but now you talk about lebron lebron did
everything it takes to be the best
because
he stayed healthy
he's still playing yeah i think it's 19
years he's been in the league now 19
years and the stuff he's doing he's
having statistically maybe his best year
statistically he's not moving a lot
right but he's still playing playing
high levels it's crazy his offense is
sick it's insane um
you know but with that being said you
gotta pick one
that's really hard because i mean this
guy lebron he's the number one scorer in
history right now
so you're picking lebron
it's hard
you gotta pick pick one [ __ ]
i mean you have to go lebron
the reason this is why
he's played 19 years
his stats is incredible
now i can i can i can prove i can make a
point for jordan
um
but if i just look at the numbers i got
i think lebron is probably the top five
passer of all time i feel like you just
get a lot more with lebron if you're
like if you let's say you were drafting
right you're like i want lebron or i
want you you know you're going to get us
so much more with lebron
i mean
they def they they're different they are
different you know what i like to think
of is like when lebron went to the
finals in 07 against the spurs with kind
of like a very weak team eric snow was
the starting point guard um
they had a big z as the center
jordan really had to get pippin to get
over the
the pistons hump you gotta get a lot of
people to get over the pistons huh yeah
and i feel like before that he you know
well lebron had to go see wade
no for sure but he made it to the finals
though
i mean obviously they got swept by the
first dwight made it to the finals no
you're right
a lot of people made it to the finals no
you're right you're right i mean yeah
but dwight didn't make it 10 times
so right so
but jordan jordan you know
i mean and then lebron was in cleveland
so that's not fair jordan was in chicago
nobody wanted to play there carl's
carlos boozer [ __ ] lebron over and
went to the jazz he had a lot i'm a big
lebron guy it was hard for lebron i mean
i love lebron and their big offseason
move was getting anton james i almost
went to the cavs i told people to start
i almost went to the cavs what year
did when i went to the lakers so you
almost went and joined lebron yeah i was
i was talking to lebron a little bit
about going to the cavs but does lebron
call you to try to recruit you smoke
like maybe two minutes three minutes
what was his pitch to you to come to
cleveland just real quick just real
quick like you know
he called it he didn't need a pitch even
i'm five years older than him but at
that point in time in his career
legendary right so you look up to that
so i was like oh wow this is pretty dope
but um i was actually trying to go back
to indiana so when i first i was in
houston so i was trying to go back to
houston because
we just lost the lakers i wanted to
redeem myself
then um when houston said no
then i called my agent i want to go back
to indiana
then when indiana said no
then um
i tried to get to detroit
which would have been crazy that would
have been so crazy yeah i can't go to
pistons
um and then jojo dumas is the general
manager he's like nah
i almost went to the knicks
i said if isaiah i mean isaiah got in a
little issue
the nick thing was off off the table so
that's i was probably gonna be a nick at
29 years old which i was like that would
have been incredible right and then um
then
when uh when king james uh reached out
then and they're not gonna and then um
the lakers also reached out so it was
between cleveland and l.a um
when it when it boils down to it
yeah
you might have been the difference maker
in 2010 for the cavs
i was trying honestly i was trying not
to play with kobe or lebron honestly
r.i.p my brother kobe how much can i
want to play against those guys um but
then when but then
when no teams wanted me you got it
lebron the cavs did yeah all lebron did
but i couldn't get any other teams
so when that happened i had to backtrack
like yo
hey i'm playing with one of the stars
man you know and they only offer me the
minimum so i was just like whatever at
this point whatever man i'm i'm
who's the most underrated teammate you
ever had in the nba do you feel like
don't get enough flowers um well yeah
obviously like because the nba market
certain people and certain people's more
outgoing but
johnny salmons john salmons was solid
solid players he was on the kings right
yeah i remember i had him in fantasy
basketball great players john simmons
yeah um
jameson brewer from indiana pacers back
in the days he don't get no credit he
way ahead of his time um we have
jonathan bendy got hurt early bender was
nice on the pacers
was nice um
was he in the dunk contest i feel like
he might have been he could dunk his
yeah he was a beast i remember john
durant yeah he was nice same thing yeah
bender was nice for sure
may little strong a better shot blocker
but the same exact player yeah jonathan
bender was nice